All right, welcome, everybody, our last
show before the Thanksgiving break,
a few disclaimers before we start.
I'm feeling fine. I appreciate the messages of
concern continuing to pour in. I sound different
this week if you're listening, because I'm in a
different location, different microphone. I look
different because of different lighting. And I'm
sort of in front of a weird window, but I'm fine.
It's just the lighting. I've not gone pale or red
or whatever people are worried about. I appreciate
the concern. I'm feeling fine heading into the
Thanksgiving holiday, hopefully safely. And a few
things I want to talk about with you today before
we go on our brief Thanksgiving break. First of
all, now that Donald Trump has come as close as he
is likely to get to conceding this election to Joe
Biden, the transition has officially started, even
though it had started already. But now it's really
started. We must focus on the two Georgia Senate
runoffs as the primary focus of the next roughly
eight weeks. And, well, actually, it's eight weeks
until Biden is sworn in, but it's only about
six weeks until these runoffs on January 5th.
There will be two runoff elections in Georgia,
which will determine do Republicans control
the Senate for Joe Biden's first two years or do
Democrats control the Senate for Joe Biden's first
two years? One race is incumbent Republican David
Perdue versus Democratic challenger John USCIRF.
The other race is Republican incumbent Carly
Loffler, one of the most corrupt senators in
the Senate versus Democratic challenger Raphael
Warnock. These will be tough races, but they are
winnable races. And we have to understand
it'll be tough. But we can win both ideas.
We can hold at the same time. The Loffler versus
Warnaco race is reportedly a one point race. Some
polls say it's Loffler plus one. Others say
it's Warnaco plus one. What does this mean?
I'll wait. You know, I don't have to tell you,
everybody who votes in Georgia must vote legal
votes. Obviously, it's basically a tie. The
other race, Perdue versus OSF, also right
in there. The latest we have, we have only one
recent poll from last week which says it's 49 49.
Previous polls showed that Perdue was a little
bit ahead by three or even as many as four points.
It's a statistical tie right now. They are
uphill battles. The path forward is putting
all of our effort into these races. Anybody who
wants to phone bank can phone bank donate if
you can afford to pandemic's safe. Doorknocking is
being organized in Georgia. If you are in Georgia,
voter registration, including the work of Stacey
Abrams, could be the difference maker here. Her
work has been unbelievable. And on the other side
there, this is this is more funny because it's so
self-defeating than anything else. There are
some Republicans that are so mad at Trump and
other Republicans for, I guess not fighting
more to steal the presidency from Joe Biden,
that there are some Republicans in Georgia saying
boycott the Senate runoff, just don't go and vote.
And to them, I say, what a great idea. I hope that
that's exactly what you do, help us defeat those
incumbent incumbent Republicans. We really cannot
overstate the importance of these races. If USCIRF
and Warnock win, it's 50/50 in the Senate
that makes Kamala Harris the deciding vote.
This means tax reform might be done. This
means health care expansion might be done,
maybe infrastructure and more. Now they will all
be battles. Understand that even with control of
the Senate, you will still be up against the more
centrist wing of the Democratic Party. But these
become battles worth fighting, I believe. And
I know some people say, David, you're being too
pessimistic. I believe that without the Senate,
none of this gets done. I just don't see how
you do tax reform and health care expansion and
infrastructure the way Joe Biden wants to do it,
focused on clean green energy. I don't see how you
do it without the Senate. If if the Democrats are
not able to win those two seats, Joe Biden will
be relegated to governing at least for two years,
essentially by executive order on all but the most
uncontroversial things. And remarkably little will
get done in terms of big legislation.
So this is where the focus has to be.
And meanwhile, Donald Trump really seems to be
running out of gas. Let's discuss that next.